i'm gonna tell you something every
person in their life has had a million
dollar idea
no doubt no doubt
it's just gonna take action
you definitely do not need to go to
business school to become an
entrepreneur
i started spanx as a frustrated consumer
i had five thousand dollars set aside in
savings
i simply wanted to be able to wear white
pants to a party and have nothing show
underneath it
the entire time everyone told me no and
said this is not a great idea but let me
tell you one thing
that means you've come up with something
brand new
take it as a compliment this master
class is for
anyone out there who's in search of an
idea has an idea and doesn't know what
to do next is wanting to start a
business or has already started a
business
guess in some way i'm saying i think
this class is for everybody
before i started spanx i actually was
selling fax machines door-to-door
i got kicked out of building after
building and one day i thought
i'm in the wrong movie i call the
producer call the director
this is not my life what happened i can
tell you the things that i focused on
very early on three things make it
sell it build awareness people are
looking for that
i want to be 100 million dollar company
in the first year and i'm going to raise
as much money as i possibly can
and just check in with yourself on that
and
be willing to start small
[Music]
why are you doing this what's the why
and who are you in the world
share that part of the story i mean the
more vulnerable you're willing to be
the deeper the connection will be with
your consumers i hope that you're tuning
in
and you're seeing me and i become the
example that you needed to say
check yes you can i'm sarah blakely
and this is my master class
[Music]
you